la historia de tara nom zeidi es el
reflejo de la historia de su país una de
esperanza ahora afectada por el regreso
del talibán al poder
es difícil confiar en ellos y la falta
de confianza y de comodidad nos obligará
a vivir con miedo es como si alguien ha
sido sentenciado a muerte y lo van a
matar en cualquier momento es una
sensación horrible
para nombre groso de su exilio en miran
en 2011 desde entonces ha luchado por
los derechos de las mujeres vio dos
décadas de progreso de derechos sociales
y económicos pero la visibilidad que las
mujeres ganaron pacientemente durante 20
años ya está desapareciendo
con mucho coraje fui a la oficina a
trabajar pero los soldados no me dieron
permiso para ingresar me dijeron que el
régimen había cambiado que no podía
ingresar y que me fuera a casa actual
jamás me la semana con el derecho de las
mujeres a la educación y al trabajo se
está viendo amenazado además hace poco
fueron eliminadas algunas imágenes
publicitarias en las calles con fotos de
mujeres las mujeres perdieron todo lo
que tenían estoy segura que vivir en
afganistán será cada vez más duro y muy
difícil para las mujeres el mayor temor
de tara no es volver a vivir bajo las
restricciones del talibán tal y como
sucedió entre 1996 y 2001